p.m all right from chocolate to medicare
now that medicare enrollment period is
over
it's still important to stay on top of
your health insurance ecos medicare
solutions is always here to help
the great thing about an advisor here
our independent agents for
you know for um explaining medicare to
our clients
is that you know we get paid by the
carrier
okay you may think that's biased but we
get paid the same
no matter what plan we choose from any
carrier
so it's unbiased for us to push you in
any one direction
because our compensation is the same
we're going to find a plan that best
fits your needs not just the one plan
somebody calls you about
we're gonna go over all the plans from
all the major carriers
here in clark county or washoe county or
nye county
wherever it may be that's what we're
gonna do face to face
over the phone or on the webinar however
you feel most comfortable and wherever
you feel most comfortable meeting
we we have a staff of 30
agents willing to help you trained you
know by me
trained by medicare trained by the
carriers
we got to certify every single year with
80
continuing education hours like a
typical
doctor or lawyer it's only 20. so a
little bit about me
is i am a gerontologist a gerontologist
is the social
psychosocial part of aging in our senior
population
geriatrician is the medical doctor
gerontologist
psycho-social and i was also a
professor at loyola marymount university
and
in california and i served 22 years in
the united states air force so i'm a
veteran
and i love my veterans and if you have
questions how
the va or tricare works with the
medicare
you give me a call and i'll walk you
through it so when annual enrollment
period comes around
it we can begin start to talk about that
on
october 1st as federally mandated
october 1st
we can begin selling october 15th and we
must end
december 7th if you don't do anything
during that period
you're in what's called lock-in there
are other enrollment periods out there
but this is the key time that you can
make any changes
during this time and they all will be
effective january 1st
when our clients or someone sees
commercials on tv they're going to see
typically one plan and they're going to
talk about how wonderful
and great they are or or they're going
to tell you
hey you if you do this you don't got to
pay your part b or if you do this you
you're going to get dental
or you're going to get money back okay
so what we do is we sit down with you
and we show you all those plans and
we'll show you exactly what those
commercials are talking about
some more fishing commercials and if you
qualify i guarantee we'll get you
get you those qualifications for if it
would be
dental or it would be your part b uh
getting
refunded to you through some type of
give back program
but whatever it is whatever you see you
call me and we'll sit down and we'll
talk about it and i'll make sure you
you understand exactly what the
commercial is talking about or exactly
what
that carrier was trying to describe in
their program
eco's medicare medicare solutions a call
at 702-277-4753
or visit ecosmedicaresolutions.com and
remember
this is a free service for our local
seniors we'll be right back